[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à la veille des Jeux Olympiques
d'insbrck les grands spécialistes du
saut au trempelin on pris les devant en
participant aux compétitions
internationales du début de la saison et
notamment au saut de Garmish kir en
albagne de l'Ouest le trempelin de gmich
est l'un des plus impressionnants du
monde sur ce trempelin en effet ce ne
sont plus des skilleurs il se
métamorphose on dirait des
[Musique]
oiseaux des oiseaux qui perdent parfois
leurs ailes en cours de route triste
retour à la réalité pour ceux qui
croyaient déjà avoir vaincu
l'espace mais peu importe pour les
autres les réussites sont
[Musique]
triomphales
c'est le cas des Finlandais Konen et
alonen qui sont vraiment les maîtres de
la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
spécialité niiki la capitale de Chypre
vient à nouveau de connaître les
épreuves sanglantes avait semblé réglé
en 1959 la conférence de Londres cette
conférence où l'Angleterre représenté
par Monsieur Lyd abandonnait la tutelle
de l'île et où Monseigneur macarios
devenant le leader d'un pays indépendant
ouvrait une are nouvelle que la
population de Chypre toute entière grec
et turc accueillaient avec ferveur les
uns ont passé et l'enthousiasme est
tombé entre les 450000 Grecs et les
100000 Turcs qui vivent à Chypre les
querelles ancestrales se sont réveillées
et le sang a recommencé de couler prise
en amphilade par les tireurs isolés la
rue Ledra l'artère la plus animée de
nikzi qui sépare les deux quartiers grec
et tur est devenu la rue
sanglante cette terrifiante atmosphère a
créé dans les quartiers proches une
panique bien compréhensible et il a
fallu évacuer hors de la ville des
familles entières chassées de leur foyer
par la crainte des combats de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rue
quant à la minorité turque elle s'est
barricadée dans le quartier où elle vit
rassemblée gardée à chaque coin de rue
par des barricades de fortune occupé par
des volontaire à la détente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
facile jours durant nikzi a vécu sous la
terreur des réactions imprévisibles des
deux camps le CESS le feu décidé d'un
commun accord sur l'intervention du
représentant de l'Angleterre monsieur
dunc Sandis et la remise au général Jung
du commandement des troupes
anglo-greco-turques stationné dans l'île
ont ramener le calme pour un
[Musique]
temps mais d'autres incidents sanglant
renaissaient en d'autres points le
monastère grec de galactoforousa avait
été attaqué par un commando de cypriotte
turc et l'on n'y retrouvait que des
cadavres la trêve mal respectée avait
des fissures ou la violence de part et
d'autre se donnait encore libre
cours et la liste des morts n'est sans
doute hélas pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
définity pour cette population déchirée
le sang et les larmes sont les mêmes
chez les Grecs que chez les Turcs il
faut que cesse ce drame entre deux
communauté établie et condamné à vivre
ensemble sur la même
[Musique]
terre lorsque sur l'aéroport d'Aman où
l'attendait le roi Husain la silhouette
blanche de Paul VI se dessina à la porte
de l'avion le monde entier put se dire
que comm c'est une aventure aux résonan
infinie en effet jamais aucun pape
depuis Saint-Pierre ne s'est rendu sur
cette terre où le Christ naquit vécu et
mouru dans son geste Paul 6 avait
enfermé un sens de portée incalculable
la main tendue aux églises séparées et
l'assurance que le sens écuménique de
l'église était sa première préoccupation
sur la route d'Aman à Jérusalem en pays
jordanien le Saint-Père voulu faire sa
première halte au pont du Jourdain à
l'endroit où selon la tradition Jésus
reçu le B des mains de Jean-Baptiste
ainsi se marquait dès la première heure
l'esprit dans lequel le Saint-Père
accomplissait son voyage il retrouvait
les pas du
[Musique]
Christ ce voyage était donc d'abord un
pèlerinage mais l'enthousiasme de la
foule jordanienne en faisait à l'arrivée
à Jérusalem et dans le long cheminement
de la voie douloureuse une que un vrai
semblable où le pape disparaissait
presque
complètement
dans la nuit maintenant complète devant
la basilique du Saint Sépulcre le
Saint-Père célébra sa première messe en
Terre sainte avant d'aller se recueillir
dans la crypte où fut enseveli le corps
du Christ et où l'on voit toujours la
pierre du
[Musique]
tombeau
le lendemain à Mido Sa Sainteté Paul 6
entrait en Israël où répondant au
souhait de bienvenue du président de la
République israélienne monsieur chazar
le pape ajoutait à son discours fait en
français le mot hébreu qui est à la fois
un salut et un souhait Shalom la
paix Nazareth où le Christ vécut son
enfance où il fut ouvrier charpentier
attendait le pape avec
[Musique]
Fiè
dans la ville qui compte aujourd'hui
35000 habitants le pape allait bénir les
murs de l'église inachevée de
l'Annonciation toujours au milieu d'une
foule dont la chaleur rompant parfois
les barrages l'emportait dans ses
[Applaudissements]
remous
le voyage continuait vers la montagne
sainte du Tabor une basilique marque
l'endroit où Jésus apparut à trois de
ses disciplle dans la gloire et la
lumière de sa transfiguration divine par
un chemin sommé de rose le pape s'en est
allé méditer sur ces lieux sacrés où
commença la grande aventure apostolique
par les mots diss à Pierre vous serez
pêcheurs
[Musique]
d'homme c'est au retour à Jérusalem que
Deva déroul l'un des actes les plus
importants de ce voyage historique Paul
VI rencontrait atenagoras 1er patriarche
de Constantinople et premier pontif des
églises orthodoxes séparé de Rome depuis
10 siècles rencontre pleine d'espoir
dont le sens se dégage peut-être plus
entier au tout premier berceau du
christianisme à Bethléem qui au-dessus
des frontières de barbelé a fait voler
les
colons c'est encore au milieu d'une
foule compacte que le successeur de
Saint-Pierre est allé prier à l'église
de la Nativité élevée au-dessus de la
grotte où naquis celui qui annonça la
paix pour les hommes de bonne volonté
c'est peut-être sa méditation en ce lieu
sacré qui inspira au pape Paul VI le
pressant appel à la paix qu'il adressa à
tous les chefs d'État et à tous les
peuples qu'il collabore plus
efficacement pour obtenir la paix et la
vérité dans la justice dans une liberté
et dans un amour
fraternel
[Musique]